Greenland the largest island in the world a
nice desert at the mercy of the ocean lashed
by Arctic winds populated by Seals and polar
bears where time seems to have stopped flowing
but beyond that what do we really know about
Greenland? We came here with very specific
purposes to dispel hard to die myths to tell
you the parable of an inhospitable land shaped
by Colonial domination that aspires to be
a nation to show you how this is not just
a white spot drawn on a map but rather
a part of our history as human beings.
Welcome to Greenland.
for nearly four centuries settlers traded walrus
tusks and seal skins with Iceland and Norway in
exchange for food wood and iron tools. At the
time however the Norse villages in Greenland were
already falling into ruin. Within a few decades
nothing more was known of the inhabitants. The
crown of Copenhagen interested in keeping the
Artic trade routs active and hunting whales,
in order to undermine the then Dutch competition
tried to reestablish contacts with the Lost
Colony. 300 years of inconclusive expeditions
followed until in 1721 the Lutheran pastor Hans
Egede landed where the first Danish settlement
in Greenland would be born: Godthab... Good Hope
since 1979 Godthab has been renamed nuuk which
means cape and it's the capital of Greenland at
that time aged believed not only that he would
meet survivors but also that these having been
isolated for centuries still preached Catholicism
or paganism and that they spoke a some form of Old
Norse. Egede was wrong. The Greenland coasts had
now become home to another people... The Inuit.
the term Inuit, in the singular inuk, means
people and has replaced the derogatory and
erroneous Eskimos which means those who wears no
shoes. These Arctic people descend from the first
Siberian men who migrated over the millennia to
the Northern areas of Alaska Canada and Greenland,
and have always lived by fishing and hunting
animals, such as polar bears seals reindeer and
whales. Today 90% of greenlanders are Inuit
and largely speak the Kalaallisut language,
which is completely different from
the European ones. In some Villages
like in Tasiilaq, on the East Coast, the
Inuit have never abandoned their roots.
Thule, the most direct ancestors of the Inuit,
penetrated Southwest Greenland around the 14th
century, there is when the Nordic Atlantic
area was hit by a phenomenal climate known
as the little Ice Age which is believed to have
caused The Disappearance of the Norse colonies. In
Godthab, Egede's mission was to convert the locals
which were perceived as Savages it was a slow
process hindered by the presence of the Angakkuit,
the so-called Inuit shamans, who are seen as
holders of knowledge in both the religion and
medical fields however the Danes began to populate
the western coast, expanded Godthab and founded
the harbor of Jakobshavn, the modern Ilulissat.
With the creation of the royal greenlandic
company in 1774 Copenhagen established a
monopoly aimed at acquiring in exchange for coffee
and tobacco meat leather and handcraft products
including "Tupilac", bone statuettes depicting
demons from Inuit mythology. Thus by changing
perspective the units began to deprive themselves
of resources that had always been necessary to
their subsistence and access Western Market logic.
This trend was frowned upon by Danish officials,
who feared that the Inuits would soon lose
their essence and therefore their usefulness.
Furthermore in 1814 Denmark was forced to cede
Norway to Sweden after being defeated in the
Napoleonic Wars and to rely only on the Icelandic
and greenlandic colonies. Then the presumed desire
to preserve the Inuit culture was accompanied
by the need to make it more efficient. In 1835
the Royal company suggested building wooden
houses to replace the traditional Inuit homes,
there is huts and summer tents made of bones and
fabrics. Although famous the igloos were nothing
more than shelters used for hunting and fishing
and although it is redundant to underline it...
no, no single Inuk still lives in the igloos.
In 1856 the colonial administrators decreed
that each settlement would have to elect its
own representatives in charge of supervising
the society. However only the most experienced
hunters could carry out this task. In other words
the Royal company delegitimized the Angakkuit,
the shamans, and destabilized a proven social
structure. The same thing happened when Denmark
decided to claim greenand in its entirety.
shortly thereafter the advancement of European
claims on the Arctic routes and the outbreak of
the two World Wars would have made Greenland
geostrategic potential evident. In 1941 with
Copenhagen occupied by the Nazi army, the
Danish ambassador to Washington, Henry Kaufman,
allowed the United States to establish five
temporary military bases on the island. These
gave an important tactical advantage to the Allied
Air Force. However once the conflict was over,
the White House didn't give up, in fact
the United States aspired to exploit the
island for an anti-soviet purpose and to take
possession of cryolite, a mineral use for for
the manufacturing of aluminium present on
the south coast. In great secrecy in 1951,
American Engineers began to build a gigantic Air
Base in Thule, still operating today. In 1968 the
crash of an American fighter caused the dispersion
of four tactical thermonuclear bombs ,which
exploded and contaminated the entire Thuli area
one of the four warheads is still missing today.
But 2 years before this incident, Washington had
decommissioned another Secret Base, Camp Century,
which was supposed to host 600 nuclear missiles
capable of reaching Moscow. These US military
projects forced the local Inuit communities to
move even 100 km away. At the same time the noise
and the clangs of the machines irreparably
affected ecosystems that had until then been
immersed in silence. In any case Greenland's
most important resource still remains the sea.
Already in the first half of the 20th century
in Copenhagen they had noticed how the fishing
of shrimps, halibut, cod and salmon could
generate much greater profits than those
deriving from traditional seal or reindeer
hunting. In 1953 driven by decolonization,
the Danish government elevated Greenland to
the status of an autonomous Province. Over
the course of 20 years Copenhagen launched
two development plans called G50 and G60,
aimed at modernizing the Island's fishing
industry and settlements. These welfare
policies have certainly improved
the quality of Greenlandic life.
Despite its obvious advantages, modernization
brought about much larger and more sudden
upheavals than those suffered previously.
The abolition of the monopoly of the royal
Greenland company and the construction of New Port
facilities removed the social role of the hunter,
who until 50 years earlier colonial officials
had considered the Pinnacle of Inuk society.
To guarantee greater productivity of the
locals now employed in the fish factories, the
urbanization projects involved the forced movement
of thousands of people from the villages to the
new Urban centers inhabited, this time equipped
with shops schools and hospitals. Apart from from
barracks and wooden buildings Nuuk is today
the emblem of an accelerated development that
doesn't take into consideration the lifestyle of
the Inuits. Just think of the so-called block P,
an abnormal ghetto residential structure built in
the 60s, now demolished which was said to contain
1% of the entire greenlandic population. Thanks
to the opportunities that opened up on the island,
Inuits found themselves busy with tasks they had
never done before. However they were paid 25% %
less than Danes in the same positions. To earn
an equivalent salary an Inuk had to have lived at
least 10 years in Denmark. Economic discrimination
went hand in hand with some perverse intentions:
in 1951 the Danish authorities took 22
init children away from their families,
to send them to Denmark and train them as
the future greenlandic ruling class. This
experiment needless to say failed. Half
of those children died at a young age and
half were affected by mental disorder. Between
the 60s and' 70s, under government directives,
Danish doctors placed intrauterine coils
(contraceptive instruments) in the bodies
of approximately 4,000 Inuit women and
girls. In doing so in just a few years,
the greenlandic birth rate, considered excessively
high at the time, was halved. The criticism and
discontent towards the entire postcolonial system
led to the birth of the autonomous parliament of
Nuuk in 1979. Greenland chose its current flag in
1985, the same year it left the European economic
Community (to protect its waters from the probable
siege of foreign fishing boats). In fact today
Greenland is not part of the European Union and
has enjoyed an autonomous government since 2009.
Nonetheless the fate of the largest island in the
world is undefined. According to United Nations,
Greenlandic society suffers from the lack of
adequate housing and Healthcare facilities.
It suffers from an educational system that
allows young people to emancipate themselves.
In 2014 the Nuuk government created a
Reconciliation Commission, in order to
heal relations with Denmark. It will be a long
process that will require the acquisition of
greater awareness both on the part of the
Inuit community and the Danish authorities.
myself having lived here for nearly 1 and
1/2 years I've only experienced like one
episode of a drunk person coming up
and saying I should go back where I
came from uh I've heard other stories where
people got confronted during a night out or
at a concert also being asked to go home
but I would say like in general people I
meet are very open and honest that's
the thing about Greenlandic people.
The wounds of the colonial
period perhaps have never healed.
For the lower social classes, I think, most of
the stuff that I experience, alcoholism is a big
problem like the social evolution kinda happened
too fast so to speak uh a lot of people lost their
jobs because they had to be moved out of the
smaller cities into like Nuuk. There are like
a couple of think we call them the blocks at the
you can't really see them here like where people
got lodged in together and I think forcing a
person who his whole life has gone fishing,
gone hunting, to suddenly work in a factory
is kind of soul sucking in a weird way I could
imagine that and also having access to alcohol
kind of messed a lot of people up I would imagine.
The issues of greenlandic society do not
end here at all and now more than ever
in a 21st century marked by uncertainty
and competition between Global Powers,
Greenland is destined to deal with the
inevitability of the future and its challenges,
its opportunities. But we will talk
more about this in the next video.